deutschland braucht ein
Mentalitätswechsel es hat sich
spätestens durch Corona eine
vollkasko-mentalität durchgesetzt jeder
versteckt sich hinter Gesetzen will
keine Verantwortung übernehmen in den
Talkshows bei Corona
Bundespolitiker hat die Verantwortung zu
Landespolitik geschoben anderer wiederum
zu Kommunalpolitik und da müssen wir
raus ich möchte eine Mentalität des
Machens dass derjenige eine Idee hat
einfach mal losläuft ohne dass da immer
einer ist und sagt es geht nicht weil
ich habe einen Vorbild ist der
Oberbürgermeister aus Rostock der Mann
heißt Madsen ein Topmann weil der
richtig mutig war der hat einfach mal
gemacht in der Krise und hat de facto
Klick and meet erfunden indem er gesagt
hat im Einzelhandel der Kunde anruft
oder im Internet bestellt kann er die
Sachen abholen ganz Deutschland hat es
nachgemacht wenn wir dieses im Deutschen
Bundestag
diskutiert hätten werden sofort die
Bremser und Bedenkenträger gekommen und
es wäre kaputt gewesen diese Idee und
deswegen möchte ich eine
Föderalismusreform von unten das in den
Landkreisen jeder was ausprobieren kann
Abstand nehmen kann von Gesetzen und
wenn etwas funktioniert Rollis im ganzen
Land aus wenn es nicht funktioniert wann
hat es in die Tonne einfach mal machen
ist es immer noch ihr traumhell in mein
Bein als ich das Buch gelesen habe hatte
ich schon das Gefühl dass sie sehr
diskussioniert sind sie sind in der
Politik gestartet und hatten wie ich es
in dem Buch entnommen habe andere
Vorstellungen als es dann wirklich ist
ist es jetzt ihr Traum oder sagen Sie
dieses verkrustete System den
politischen Betrieb kann man erneuern
also grundsätzlich zu zu zum ersten Teil
ich habe mir das alles anders
vorgestellt in der Politik ich wollte
wirklich die die Welt verändern und weiß
nicht ob ich blauäugig war oder naiv
aber ja ich wollte die Bildungspolitik
zu einer nationalen Aufgabe machen ich
wollte den Bierdeckel von Friedrich Merz
umsetzen wo eine Steuererklärung drauf
passt ich wollte Bürokratie abschaffen
und ich weiß noch mein Vater der hatte
eine Buchhandlung und der sagte wenn
mein Sohn jetzt in die Politik geht
damit die Bürokratie endlich abgeschafft
ich habe dem das immer gesagt heute sagt
er zu mir seitdem du drin bist nimm die
noch mal richtig zu richtig so und
deswegen habe ich mir jetzt auch die
Frage gestellt das kann nicht so
weitergehen so und deshalb ist meine
These die Politik ist nur im krisenmodus
unterwegs nur in krisenmodus erst war
die Finanzkrise dann die Energiewende
dann die Euro-Krise dann die
flüchtlingskrise dann die corona-krise
jetzt die ukraine-krise und in jeder
Krise sagt man wenn die Krise vorbei ist
dann packen wir das mit der
Bildungsreform an Bürokratie schaffen ab
und so weiter und dann ist aber schon
die nächste Krise da und damit muss
Schluss sein kurz um die Krise darf nie
wieder als Entschuldigung gelten für
etwas was man in der Zeit nicht macht
als ehemaliger Bundesminister teilen Sie
das was helenemann sagt sind sie auch
desillusioniert worden nein bin ich
überhaupt nicht das teile ich nicht
ansonsten teile ich weitestgehend diese
Analyse bis auf einen Punkt vielleicht
brauchen wir einen Mentalitätswechsel
das erinnert mich so an Kohls moralische
Wände von der gesprochen hat ich glaube
die Mentalität ist in vielen Bereichen
sehr wohl da aber wenn zum Beispiel zum
Beispiel etwas zu machen
ich hatte einen Freund leider viel zu
viel verstorben der klassische
Unternehmer eigentlich nach Schumpeter
wie der den Unternehmertyp definiert hat
der große österreichische Nationalökonom
aber genau das war der Punkt der hatte
eine Idee wenn wir zusammen saßen sagt
der Mensch das will auch was denn musste
ich ihm sagen
kann aber nicht morgen an sonst wird
deine Baustelle wieder stillgelegt weil
ja ich merke es überhaupt nicht sich mit
den ganzen Unwegbarkeiten die jetzt auf
ihn zukam zu beschäftigen und das
widerspricht auch dem klassischen
unternehmertypus mit all dem was damit
zusammenhängt so sie haben die
Landkreise angesprochen sagen sie steigt
Landkreise Städte und Gemeinden ist viel
besser als auch Hamburgs aber glaube ich
auch darauf verständlich aber machen
so und wenn Sie heute
sehr konkret
ich hätte noch mal nachgemessen wenn ich
gewusst hätte dass dieses Thema kommt da
stehen 12 Häuser das sollen in dieser
Reihe von 12 Häusern zwei genau nein
gebaut werden wie glauben Sie wie dick
ist die Akte um das zu genehmigen
die ist so dick für zwei Häuser im
übrigen die Kinder des Eigentümers bauen
sein da gibt es auch keine Probleme mit
Nachbarn überhaupt nichts essen und das
ist Irrsinn schlichtweg Irrsinn ist es
ihnen denn gelungen als Bundesminister
in Ihrem speziellen Bereich damals die
Bürokratie abzubauen
aber Sie müssen da auch mit der eigenen
Klientel mit den eigenen Leuten sehr ins
Gericht gehen ich will Ihnen folgendes
sagen da haben sie einen neuen
förderbestand der geschaffen wird von
der EU Landwirte kriegen Geld und jetzt
geht es darum wer bearbeitet die
entsprechenden Anträge da kommen die
Landwirtschaftskammern unseren das
müssen wir aber machen dann kommen die
Ämter für Agrarstrukturen nein viel
besser ist es das ist bei uns aufgehoben
wird jeder kommt und sagt eine Aufgabe
für uns
da eigentlich auch stellen damit
zusammen damit hängen Beförderungen
zusammen und so weiter und dann müssen
sie eine Entscheidung treffen als du
häufig habe ich auch manchmal machen
müssen wenn dann Kompromisse gemacht
sowohl als auch
angetreten damals als basta Kanzler und
sie waren doch sein Minister also was
passiert das mit dem Bass da ist Unsinn
das ist gröpster Unsinn das hat
irgendjemand mal in die Welt gesetzt wie
das so ist aber er ist auch gerne so
aufgetreten Herr Schröder wenn man sich
alte Videos anguckt ich war damals noch
ein bisschen zu klein damit kann ich
jetzt nicht komplizieren
und guter Zigarre nein ich habe es ja im
kabinettten erlebt so und das Schröder
nicht ab konnte zu Recht ich weiß ja
nicht wie es in anderen Kabinetten
gewesen ist wenn jemand über einen
bestimmten Vorgang über eine
Kabinettsvorlage lange oberflächlich
diskutiert wurde da Brache ab und sagte
mach deine Hausarbeiten der konnte man
den Kram auch wieder Unternehmen und neu
wieder versuchen die Kabinetts voll
lange durchzubringen norddeutsch sagen
wir Gesabbel konnte er nicht ab und das
ist richtig und vernünftig das ist
nämlich auch regierten aufzuhören mit
dem Gesabbel was es gibt und zu sagen
sag was du willst es ist richtiges
falschen hat er den Vorteil dass man
sich noch sagen er konnte sehr schnell
Vorgänge erfassen auch wenn die nicht
unbedingt mit seinem angewolften Wissen
zu tun hatten aber sehr schnell erfassen
stellte gezielt Fragen und die musste
man in der Sitzung auch beantworten
können das erwartete er von seinen
Fachministern und da sagt er schon mal
komm her schlecht gemacht sehr sehr
Barsch vielleicht auch aber ich habe mir
sagen dass sie das war bei anderen auch
so ich halte es für notwendig Frau du
wieder wie sehen Sie das denn ist in der
Politik zu viel Gesabbel wie es gerade
genannt gesammelt auf jeden Fall ich
finde aber ein bisschen Herr Lindemann
was Sie gesagt haben der mir gesagt wenn
man im Landkreis ist und dann macht man
einfach mal und dann soll man auch keine
Gesetz achten sie haben das
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen überspitzt
formuliert und gar nicht so gemeint ist
ja schon ganz gut dass man Gesetze
beachtet die gibt es ja aus einem Grund
und ich finde ein bisschen sie haben
gesagt vielleicht war es naiv in den
Politik reinzugehen und das nicht zu
erwarten vielleicht ist es wirklich ein
Stück weit naiv gewesen denn man weiß ja
dass eigentlich das Wesen der Demokratie
ist dass man eben auch den Vorteil
dessen hat dass da verschiedene Leute
mitreden dass da eine Meinungsbildung
und Willensbildung stattfindet auf Basis
dessen dass verschiedene Parteien die
verschiedene Leute gewählt haben dazu
sagen kommen dass man dann Kompromiss
findet und das ist doch auch das was
worüber wir uns eigentlich freuen können
es gibt in der Demokratie einfach so mal
entscheiden dass das nicht nur eine
Person ist eine Partei macht aber wenn
es nicht zu viele Leute die da mitreden
wir blähen die ganzen Ministerien auf in
den letzten zehn Jahren tausende mehr
Mitarbeiter der mittlerweile
42 beauftragte das
Wirtschaftsministerium hat sich fast
verdoppelt in den letzten 10 15 Jahren
es geht immer mehr da müssen wir noch
irgendwann mal einen Bild machen und der
andere Punkt ist ich möchte nicht
Gesetze aufheben aber ich spüre halt
wenn einer eine Idee hat und geht den
Bundestag und will das für ganz
Deutschland durchsetzen kommen sofort
die Bedenkenträger und sagen warum etwas
nicht geht wenn man aber vor Ort etwas
ausprobiert sind die komischerweise
nicht da und deswegen will ich es
umdrehen und sagen okay dann machen wir
es in Zukunft so es wird ausprobiert
wenn es läuft machen was überall ein
ganz kurzes Beispiel bei mir in
Paderborn soll die erste Stadt im Stehen
mit autonomen fahren parallel zum
regulären Verkehr dazu gibt es in
Deutschland keine Regulierung ich kann
ihn jetzt schon sagen dass dort
wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder Jahre bis
das geht dann kommen die ganzen
mitdenkenträger und wie viel tote kann
es geben und so weiter lasst uns doch so
machen wir probieren das einfach mal aus
in Paderborn und wenn es funktioniert
machen es alle nach so schaffen wir das
um in Deutschland
bei Corona erlebt wo plötzlich alle
andere Regeln hatten und das war ja auch
in Teilen hat man sich gedacht warum
kann das nicht national gelöst sein aber
Corona ist auch ein schönes Beispiel
warum hat man nicht bei Corona gesagt
wir probieren mal was aus wir lassen mal
eine Stadt das machen will
wir lassen den Einzelhandel mal offen
machen parallel eine Studie schnell und
schauen ist es wirklich so dass im Fach
Einzelhandel im Brautmodengeschäft im
normal also Brautmodengeschäft ist ja
auch ein schönes Beispiel ob die
überlaufen sind während Corona wirklich
auch mal zu bezweifeln aber auch ganz
normale
Kleidungsgeschäfte ja und dann prüfen
wir das vor Ort und wenn es funktioniert
lassen wir den gesamten Einzelhandel in
Deutschland auf evidenzbasiert wurde
nicht gemacht es wurde hier diskutiert
in sogenannten
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und dann
kam das raus was sie gerade beschrieben
haben fragen wir einmal den Unternehmer
in der Runde was halten Sie denn von dem
Vorschlag dass die Politik mal mehr
macht vor Ort und weniger debattiert
also das wäre wichtig weil ich glaube
man merkt auch jetzt gerade in der
aktuellen Krise das zu viel geredet wird
es wird zu viel lamentiert und immer
wieder werden Expertenkommission
gegründet man muss einfach mal machen
und das ist gerade wichtig die
gaspreisbremse ist eigentlich ein
Beispiel dafür wir haben in ganz Europa
funktioniert wir gehören zu den letzten
Ländern die gerade darüber diskutieren
und uns sprechen teilweise davon dass
ihr mehr als April eingeführt werden
soll und da muss es einfach viel
effizienter sein also Politiker sollten
sich auch ein bisschen Beispiel an
Unternehmer nehmen wo man einfach mal
auf den Tisch hauen sagt wir müssen das
jetzt mal machen das ist eigentlich
schon echt richtig
davon gesprochen dass man sich nicht an
Gesetze hält er hatte einen Stichwort
genannt das ganz wichtig ist
Verantwortung wir haben eine gewisse
personale und institutionelle
verantwortungsvorweigerung ich könnte
ihn in raummengen aus der
Kommunalpolitik da bin ich auch über 40
Jahre drin dazu nennen ein Vorgang der
eigentlich völlig klar ist wo man sogar
die die beteiligt werden müssen schon im
Vorwerk gefragt hat können wir das so
machen so Fachbehörden zum Beispiel ja
ist in Ordnung und jetzt sind sie bei
einem Beamten und wenn man dem dann sagt
du ich habe schon telefoniert die machen
so mit ruft den an das ist erledigt ja
aber wir müssen noch mal das im
schriftlich machen dann sind wir auf der
sicheren Seite und jetzt sehr konkret
und tatsächlich war es so dass sie in
einer Stunde dreimal das Wort von einem
Beamten können dann sind wir auf der
sicheren Seite ein Unding und darum geht
es in Wirklichkeit die Bereitschaft
Verantwortung zu übernehmen auch wenn es
anschließend mal schief geht und da wäre
mein Appell an die Politik diesen aber
Ministerium oder sonst wo der breit ist
auch mal zu sagen ja machen wir so auch
wenn es anschließend Kritik gibt den
müssen wir dann auch in Schutz nehmen
was die Bürokratie ist angeht gehe ich
mit ihnen vollkommen mit also das
erleben wir auf jeden Tag wenn wir was
recherchieren wenn wir wollen wenn wir
was rausfinden wollen von Ministerien
oder von Ämtern oder von Behörden dass
wir da nicht so einfach eine Auskunft
kriegen sondern dass man sich immer
absichern will und dass man auf die
Zuständigkeit von anderen Behörden
verweisen dass es für uns auch
wahnsinnig frustrierend und da gehe ich
mit Ihnen voll da